here we go again against mr. Baldwin
yeah let's play something else here just
to have a variety in the games in their
recent games I really stuck to my main
openings quite a bit maybe in some
variety helps I'm a bit of a in a bit of
a slump and in the recent character a
couple of games and sometimes you just
need some different positions to to get
you kind of going here so maybe maybe d5
here yeah okay 65 was a tempo good wide
set up it's very M yeah very unambitious
so why not
okay I'm going with G form just gaining
space neither on f1 is quite quite a
strange piece
[Music]
giving me something to check that as
kind of kind of a unconventional way to
play with a four but okay
right before was already interesting
actually
okay I can't I can't prepare it's not
not a big deal so just a four here if or
maybe before it's F for something I
don't really think so okay let's put it
here this is annoying anyway and I mean
he cannot take this night I mean that
would give up c3 Farooq cc8 and so on so
and now I thought just queen bee five
isn't that problem with this pawn there
and so he eventually took okay so at
five yeah but he's in no position ready
to get something going there I don't I
don't think so
I also have moves like g5 or Queen h5
Queen h5 what is he playing then he has
to retreat and then like Queen G form
how does he defend their porn I don't
see how let's do that
it's not very yeah I mean playing for
this c3 weakness is more and let's say
straightforward but if I can just get
the F pawn this position is falling to
bits he cannot play a five maybe to stir
up trouble but it can never be enough
really so we went there okay this is a
checked no it is a checked knight c6 and
I cannot too bad i cannot somehow make a
sacrifice or it can go rook e8 actually
that sets an idea in case of f5 then my
rook is right that if he takes b7 okay
all the power to him but his dark
squares if I take F 4 are just too bad
Quincy wonders maybe a move but then I
have Roxy aid at least Quincy one
protects our form okay so I'm taking
this important poem now I thought knight
c6 to e5 have that should be should be
quite good it's a great position for the
pawn let's see how to do that H 5 H 4
and so on
or I don't know let's do that not not
yet nothing too long his pawns take a
really long while until they till they
are threatening the should f4 queen of -
hallelujah
I have no good good square for the Queen
then unfortunately how to do that
Bishop g4 maybe Queen f2 now I can
actually think about just taking I
Farouk c2 don't like to do that
[Music]
Queen trade doesn't doesn't seem doesn't
seem right but that's probably probably
exactly the way to go I still have a
pretty good initiative there d3 is
hanging yeah yeah yes he has his pawn
David very active him the pawn is also
ready to march so when I'm putting this
Bishop back maybe I cannot take him he
is not winning unfortunately I would
like to get the D pawn going maybe look
just here and then d3 yeah this is
actually quite good why not and here we
go
so is covering covering that
[Music]
threat now is should before possibly
check there and then Bishop f3
okay can still go D - let's go D - check
Jeff trickier probably the Queen trade
was good
white resins probably it was good but it
looked like yeah I don't know around him
right after this kind of business this
is a very good position for black his
dark squares I just I just lost I mean I
just terrible just have to go here and
and in excellent shape he went air form
and trying to stay up trouble yeah it's
that's an interesting question
I took now at Queen Queen age five
trying to punish this the the more yeah
the more strategically consistent
louvers rook c8 this is given by a bias
rockfish for example that's just minus
one point four so like with winning now
maybe this is easier just keeping things
simple but I've helped that this should
be great yeah picking up f1 but now Luke
c7 makes things a bit messy at the
computer I actually also assesses this
is clearly better for black but it is it
is a bit messy so probably oh that's
interesting more fun engine suggestion
that's nice yeah this and this like wins
9595 move someone plays that against you
if you know is either very strong are
using a computer very difficult to see
such a move especially if you can just
take it over there with a good position
yeah here the engine is also giving me a
very th- one point something the common
the compensation is excellent yeah here
really I rook c8 is stronger now okay I
went h5
this is stronger
keeping the C file under control so that
Quincy one is not even possible so yeah
I see that is really bad
he's he has gained a little bit of
coordination now okay Bishop f4 is even
better than this
[Music]
and now the Queen's rate is right yeah
yeah we should be to immediately also
what's good is he just falls apart now I
think ds3 oc3 mt2 amp like Windsor so
and it was okay I think I played it
played it okay can always improve young
if you you cannot aspire to play on an
honor on an engine level a blitz I mean
in any time for sure but especially in
blitz but it doesn't seem that I made
any major mistake there okay thanks for
watching